Transcriber: Yusuf Enes Akdulum
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Herkese Merhaba.
Ben Zeynep İşman.
Aile ve çocuk yazarıyım.
Aynı zamanda
ebeveynleri bilinçlendirmek, aileyi
güçlendirmek hedefiyle
organizasyonlar yapıyorum,
eğitim seminerleri düzenliyorum.
Aslında benim işim yetişkinlerle.
Ancak elbette sıklıkla çocuklarla
ve gençlerle bir araya gelebilmeyi
çok önemsiyorum.
Onları dinlemek,
onları gözlemlemek ve onları
anlamaya çalışmak
benim için çok kıymetli.
O yüzden bugün burada olduğum için
ve bu fırsat bana tanındığı için
gerçekten çok mutluyum ve çok heyecanlıyım
Umarım ilk fırsatta bu buluşmaları,
bu konuşmaları
yüz yüze gözlerinize bakarak, o enerjiyi
hissederek de yapabilirim.
Karşılıklı bir sohbet şeklinde
gerçekleştirebiliriz umarım.
Neden önemli gençlerle bir arada olmak?
Çünkü gerçekten bir toplumda
değişim gençlerle başlıyor.
Ama elbette ki gençlerin bu değişimi
yaratabilmeleri için onları gören,
onları anlayabilen ve onları destekleyen
ailelere ve büyüklere ihtiyacı var.
Dolayısıyla bu böyle
karşı cephelerde savaşan düşmanlar
gibi değil.
Aslında kol kola girdiğiniz,
yetişkinlerin, toplumdaki
söz sahibi insanların
ve gençlerin kol kola girdiği
ve tıpkı aynı takımın oyuncuları gibi
birlikte hareket etmesi gereken bir süreç.
İşte toplumumuzdaki değişim.
Bu sayede başlayacak.
Değişimi ve dönüşümü
Bu sayede görebileceğiz.
Ben şimdi bugünkü konuşmamın başlığına.
Büyük değişimler küçük adımlarla
başlar dedim.
Neden?
Bu aslında bir motivasyon
konuşması olmayacak mı ?
Şöyle düşündüm oldukça zor bir
çağın içinden geçiyoruz.
Son iki yılımızda.
Pandemi ile birlikte daha
da zorlayıcıydı.
İklim krizi kapımızı çaldı, bekliyor.
Dünyadaki savaşlar,
malum ülkemizde bir ekonomik kriz var.
Salgınlar keza beraberinde pek çok
problemi hem fiziksel, hem ekonomik
hem duygusal pek çok problemi
beraberinde getirdi.
Eğitim sistemindeki kaygan zemin, sürekli
yaşanan değişikliklerden kaynaklı
geleceğe dair bir güvensizlik
hissi hepinizin içinde var.
Dolayısıyla bu manzaraya baktığımız zaman
evet çok da parlak görünmüyor.
Gençlerin çoğu ne yazık ki umutsuz
ve aileler de bir o kadar kaygılı.
Fakat manzara böyle ise, hissettikleriniz
böyle ise ne yapacağız?
Pes edip oturup bir şeylerin değişmesini
bekleyip sürekli şikayet mi edeceğiz?
Yoksa bize sunulanları kabul edip sürekli
şikayetle mi geçireceğiz ömrümüzü?
Yoksa hayır, ben bir şey yapamam değil.
Benim de etki alanım çok kuvvetli
bir birey olarak, bir genç olarak
ne yapabilirim?
Kendi hikayemi nasıl yazabilirim?
Ve kendi hikayemle
insanlara nasıl ilham olurum?
Buna mı odaklanacağız.
İşte bu bakış açısı tamamen
bizim sorumluluğumuzda.
Bizim etki alanımızda.
Şimdi bu son iki yıl, özellikle pandemi
Bence tüm insanlığa en çok şunu öğretti.
En zor koşullara bile
nasıl da dayanma kapasitemiz olduğunu,
nasıl da güçlü varlıklar olduğumuzu
gösterdi aslında.
Yani ben bu durumun içinden
imkansız çıkamam deyip
çok umutsuzluğa kapıldığımız,
çok çöktüğümüzü hissettiğimiz anlarda dahi
düşsek de nasıl ayağa kalktığımızı.
Evet yaralandık.
Evet, çok zorlandık.
Herkesin hikayesi farklıydı
ama bir şekilde yola devam edebildik
ve bugün buradayız.
İşte bunu görmemizi sağladı.
Bu gücü görmemizi sağladı.
Ve bu devrin en büyük özelliği
aslında bu esnek dayanıklılık.
Yani bilişsel ve duygusal olarak ne kadar.
Esneyebilme kapasitesine
sahip olduğumuzu alakalı.
Çünkü belirsizlikler ve kaos çağındayız.
Geleceğe dair sadece
tahminler yürütebiliyoruz.
Bu belirsizliklere karşı
dayanıklı olabilen,
istikrarla hedefine ulaşmaya çabalayan,
3 kere düşse de 5 kere kalkabilen insanlar
var olabiliyor günümüzde.
Dolayısıyla bu esnekliği geliştirmek
temelden başlayan,
aileden başlayan bir şey.
Çok kıymetli diye düşünüyorum.
Bazı notlar aldım, izninizle
onlara da bakmak istiyorum.
Şimdi hayatta elbette ki her zaman pozitif
ve bizi destekleyen insanlarla
bir arada olmayacağız.
Özellikle iş dünyasına atıldıktan sonra.
Çokça yolumuza taş koymaya çalışan, bizi
eleştiren ve bizi kıyaslayan
ya da görmezden gelen insanlar olacak.
Fakat işte bunlara nasıl baktığımız
ve burada takınacağımız tavır
bence çok kilit bir nokta.
Kültürümüz çok tüketime odaklı,
acımasız bir kültür
ve hep başarılı ve
mutlu insan olmak çabasında herkes
hep sonuca bakıyor.
Yani başarılı mı, başarısız mı,
mutlu mu, mutsuz mu?
Oysa ki kimse o sonuca giden süreçle,
kimse o yolculukla ilgilenmiyor.
Aslında kıymetli olan
işte o yolculukta neler olduğu.
Yani o yolculukta kaç kere düştüğümüz, o
yolculukta kaç kere başarısız olduğumuz,
kaç kere başarılı olduğumuz ya
da kaç kere mutsuz olduğumuz.
Tüm bu deneyimler.
Tüm bu zorlanmalar bizi güçlendiriyor.
Bizi biz yapıyor aslında.
Büyük hikayeleri alkışlamak
günümüzün modası adeta.
Çünkü çok görsel bir kültürün içindeyiz.
Teknoloji ve sosyal medya
etrafımızı sarmış durumda
ve gerçekten o renkli dünyalar
aslında günün sonunda
bizleri demoralize ediyor.
Herkes mi bu kadar mutlu, herkes
mi bu kadar başarılı,
bir tek ben mi bu kadar yetersizim
hissine kapılmamıza neden oluyor.
Oysa ki etrafta bunca
motivasyon kırıcı şey varken,
değiştirebileceği küçücük
şeyleri görebilen,
küçücük adımlarla başlayıp,
İlmek ilmek geleceğini ören
insanların yaşadıkları süreç
çok daha büyük bir başarı simgesi aslında.
Ne yazık ki bu acımasız kültürün içinde
işte bunlar yok olup gidiyor.
Yani büyük başarıları alkışlamak
işin en kolayı.
Ama toplumda bu anlamda sayısız başarıya
sahip olmuş bir sürü insan var.
Bunların hikayelerini görmek,
bu hikayeleri görebilmek
en kıymetlisi diye düşünüyorum.
Dediğim gibi bu başarı odaklı,
mutluluk odaklı kültürde
En iyisini yapmaya çalışmayı beklersek
muhtemelen hiçbir şey yapamayız.
Yani şunda en iyi olacağım, bunda en iyi,
hiç söylenmemişi söyleyeceğim,
hiç yazılmamışı yazacağım,
hiç yapılmamışı yapacağım
gibi bir kaygıya girersek muhtemelen
bir adım bile ilerlememiz çok zor.
Bir çocuk kitabından
çok sevdiğim bir alıntıyı
paylaşmak istiyorum sizlerle.
Diyor ki
büyük şeyleri kontrol edemediğini
hissettiğinde burnunun dibindeki,
sevdiğin şeylere odaklan.
İşte aslında bugün yapmak istediğim
konuşmanın özü de bu cümlede yatıyor.
Ben ne yapabilirim ki?
Ben neyi değiştirebilirim ki?
Demek gerçekten anlamsız.
Çünkü bir kişinin bile etki alanı
çok kuvvetli.
Bir birinizin bile yaptığı şey çok
fazla değişimi yaratabilir.
En küçük adım da bir adımdır
ve işte o büyük değişimler,
küçük adımlarla başlar.
Siz küçük bir adım atıp
Günün sonunda bir şeylerin
değişmeye başladığını gördüğünüzde,
daha büyük adımları atmaya
cesaret duyarsınız.
Bugün sadece örneğin bir plastik
kullanımına dair bir farkındalığımız
ve küçücük bir davranış değişikliğimiz,
belki bir yılın sonunda doğaya bırakılan
kilolarca plastiğin azalmasına sebep olur.
Sizin bir davranış değişikliğiniz,
etrafınızdaki, etki alanınızdaki
onlarca insanın da
o davranışı değiştirmesine
ve yıllık tüketimin ciddi oranda
azalmasına sebep olur
ya da
günlük, her gün bir dostumu arayacağım,
her gün bir dostumun halini hatırını
soracağım diye küçücük bir karar
ve bunu istikrarlı bir şekilde
her gün yapmanız,
onlarca insanın hayatında
pek çok şeyi değiştirebilir.
İşte olaylara böyle bir bakış açısından
baktığımız zaman,
aslında etki alanımızın sandığımızdan
ne kadar da geniş olduğunu ve
Sabırla, sebatkarlıkla, kararlılıkla ve
hedefe odaklanarak
ve tabii ki olabildiğince pozitif bir
bakış açısıyla
neleri değiştirebileceğinizi görebiliriz.
Lütfen yapamayacaklarınıza değil,
yapabileceklerinize odaklanın.
Etki alanınızda olan şeylere bakın.
Hatta belki şimdi bu akşam kağıdı kalemi
elinize alın ve bir liste yapın.
Ne istiyorum diye sorun kendinize
ve bunu gerçekleştirmek için
neler yapabilirim?
Hemen şimdi, yarın sabah.
Küçücük bir adım da olsa.
Neler yapabilirim diye kendinize
bir liste yapın.
Bakalım o liste ne kadar
geniş bir liste olacak
ve sonra adım atın.
Sonra bir adım daha.
Yine çok sevdiğim bir sözle
bitirmek istiyorum.
Binlerce kilometrelik yolculuk
tek  bir adımla başlar.
Bunu lütfen aklınızdan çıkarmayın.
Harika bir yolculuk olmasını diliyorum
hepiniz için.
Hoşçakalın, sevgiler.